Hey, gang, welcome to Smart List. We are a sweet new podcast starring myself, Sean Hayes, Jason Bateman, and Will Arnett, and we are complete idiots. So what we do is we bring on a guest, and we ask them stuff, and they make us smarter. Hopefully. It's super cool. So please, come with us and enjoy the show. All by yourself, you got to find your own food, make your own shelter, you have 10 items
you can take into the wild with you, and you're all by yourself. You got to film the whole thing. Wait, where's this? It's a survival show called Alone that I am super addicted to right now, and it's also making our situation seem pretty luxe. You know what, how hilarious that you're addicted to a show that's called Alone. Yeah. Well, you know, it's making me feel better about the fact that you want to be alone all
the time. It makes you feel like you have company. Now, yeah, these people have serious introvert problems. Mine's more functional. Wait, babe, and be honest, did you start coronavirus just so that you could be alone? So I could wear these plaid PJ pants for four months straight? Oh, God, I smell so bad. Jason, do you like being alone, or do you like being around around here?
I am. I'm a full-blown introvert. But I mean, I'll come on out and party like the rest of them, but I need to go back inside and refill my tank. Do you think it's because you've been around people all your life, just surrounded by people constantly your whole life? Well, I don't think so, although I bet you if I was honest and I was sitting on the land down on the couch in the doctor's office, I'd probably say that a portion of my introvertness
is a bit of a stay away from me mechanism. I want my boundaries up and my privacy and all that crap. What do you think it is that you're hiding about yourself? We're rolling, right? Dr. I am. Here's the thing, you want to talk about hiding. This is a perfect segue into introducing our guest this week.
This is a person who has been hiding in plain sight for a long time. It's very difficult for this person actually to hide because they demand a lot of attention, not only because of their physical appearance and because of their size, but also because of their, well, you'll see, this person, I remember we've said before, this person needs no introduction. Shaquille Neal. I refuse to give this person an introduction because you know who this person is, they're very, very well known, I hate to say talented because it makes me mad to say that this person
is talented. Shakira. Is it Shakira? Is it Shakira? It's so close to Shakira. It's so close. Babylonia. Yeah, almost as good a dancer as Shakira.
This person was once known for doing a dance that was involved kind of like a string attached to their waist and they would kind of do this like dumb thing with their pockets. It was like the dumbest dance. Oh, no. Guess what? This week. This is Conan O'Brien. Oh, people, Mr. Conan O'Brien.
Oh, man. I got it. Yeah. I got it. Look at him. He got us close. Oh, man. Yes.
Just under the wire. Yes. Do you like sitting there and listening to us before you come on? Are you like, let's just get this over with? I thought there was some time wasting. We'll tighten it up later. I didn't need to hear Jason go on for, I think, 11 minutes about his current favorite reality show that he's binging.
I am long winded. That is some of my life. I'll never get back. But now you've got a real tasty new show to watch. I know you're looking for things to do with all your free time. I binge watch my show. That's what I do in my spare time. Repeat.
Repeat. You know what's really funny? If you guys came over and it doesn't even have to be because I have a back catalog, I just save a lot of them on, you know, I record them. So you come over to my house at any time that I'm here, you'll hear a loud laughing, and you'd come up to my room and you'd see me watching my show from 2004. Right. Say, did you hear what I just said?
Yeah. Get in here. The kids are all tied up in there and everybody's just forced to watch. If you want any more iPad time, you have to watch Daddy's show. I do. I will say once, it's a true story. I was once skiing somewhere out west, not west of where we are now. Let's not get into that.
You know what I mean? Is that what we're going to do? We're going to cut in. Okay. We don't care. We're not going to judge you for going to Deer Park. Deer Valley. You mean?
Yeah. Deer Valley. Deer Park. What an idiot. Yeah. I went to the park where you can look at deer. Stupid ass. What a great park that would be.
How's our deer park doing? Not so good. Again, nobody came to look at the deer. Let me tell you this story. So I'm skiing with my family in Deer Valley and then I hear someone say, dude, Colbert is on the other, Stephen Colbert is on the other slope. You guys must be here together. And I said, no.
And they just assume that talk show hosts call each other and make a plan. But anyway, then shortly afterwards I get a text from Stephen Colbert saying, I hear everyone says that a tall Belgian woman who looks like you is here. I immediately said, yes, I'm here. So we ski together and we ski for a bit. And at one point, the two of us, and we're skiing with his kids who are great, his family, his kids are now much older now. This story took a few years old, but his kids are now, I think, in their fifties.
Thanks for bringing on the old stories. Sorry. But anyway, we're on the ski lift together, just the two of us. And it's deadly quiet. And then he starts telling me a story about how when his show comes on, he goes in the other room while his wife and his kids watch it. And he was like, and then I hear them laugh. And then we talk about the show afterwards.
And I thought, my kids and my wife have never watched my show. It's the last thing in the world anybody wants to do. No, they will watch my show if I say, if one of their heroes is on, and I say, oh, Lin Manuel Miranda was on the show or an ads on the show, whatever, no, no, yeah, whatever. And, you know, and then they'll watch that much of it. And they'll really pay attention to the other person talking. They have no interest in watching my show. And I think that's very helpful.
I'm in the same boat. My kids hate me when we're going to get to that, Jason, don't worry. Every episode we talk about how much his Bateman's kids hate him, but Sean has never seen arrested development, which is great because two of his, you know, I didn't know that, or maybe I didn't know that. And I just poured cement over it. It's too hurtful to really think about that. I know.
I'm, you know what, you guys, you assholes, I'm going to, I'm going to watch it. I'm going to watch it. No, I'm going to start watching tonight. Sean, it doesn't hold up. It doesn't hold up. You know what it did? It was, it was a moment in comedy. I saw every episode of the Hogan family, every episode of Ozark.
That holds up. Yeah. Now, listen, I'll tell you a funny story, Ashley. I went to... Never say it's a funny story in the front. Just say I'll tell you a story and you'll be the judge. Oh, no, no, no. I meant funny, like kind of weird.
This is kind of funny. It's like, like when milk goes funny or like your uncle, like, look out for Uncle Mike. Uncle Mike went funny, but I, I was in, I went to a friend's house, friend of a friend, and they were renting Johnny Halliday. Do you know who that is? The French singer. Yes. Yes.
The French Elvis. He passed away a couple of years ago, but he was huge in France, like massive and he sold out. So we went, some new friend of a friend, we were on vacation, they were renting his house down in the Caribbean and he, we go in and he's got one of these like home theater things and he's got like, what's that thing where it's, it's like a digital DVR almost. Like you just got like movies and stuff. They used to load it up.
Restaurant? Sort of. But they used to, they used to load it up a kaleidoscope or kaleidoscope or something like that. And so you, so you could have 5,000 movies loaded into it or whatever. He had like 25 things available for viewing and they were all concert footage of his, of his own concerts. Oh no.
No way. So he had this, he had this home theater with theater seating really nice, like especially in a place in the Caribbean. And then it was all like his concert, like Johnny Halliday returns at the, you know, you know, the stadium, whatever, DP and like crazy like video of him coming off a helicopter, you know, with a hard cut and then all of a sudden he's on stage cause there's no way he, you know, he needed eight people to help him off the helicopter. Well, Conan, you'd be able to stack your top five episodes or, or, or interviews.
You could rattle those off. Of my show? Yeah. Well, the gun to your head right now. No, I couldn't. No, no. Come on. I could not.
I've been doing my show since September of 1993. Who's counting? I've been, uh, there's, there's something like 4,000 hours, uh, one sticks out. What about, would you, when you interviewed Richard Nixon, I mean, wouldn't that stick out in your head? He wasn't, you know what? I think his stories didn't have a strong finish. The thing about Nixon was, did you feel like he was lying?
No, no, it's what he was lying. It's just that he would tell, I mean, first of all, everyone thought, oh, this is great. Conan's going to get the only late night interview ever with, with Richard Nixon. This is, Nixon died as we all know in 94, so he didn't have long to live. I had him on the show and we, he was pissed because he was second on the show. He was second. Sure. It was, one of the kids in the hall was first and I don't even remember which one.
Yeah. And then he was, I don't remember which kids in the hall, but he was second and he came out and then he had these stories that he wanted to do and he had this whole bit he wanted to do about, I left a sandwich last time I was here. And it didn't pay off and the audience, what? He did. You are, you are the bit Olympics. I mean, he gave us three minutes of podcast time on just that little tiny hook I threw
him. I know. The way he did that. Let me ask you this. You've done four, whatever you said, 4,000 hours. Is that right? Yeah. It feels like five.
Guess what? Six of them. Oh God. I was about to slam myself and he slammed me. You know what? That's the tough thing about being around our net. He'll kill you before you can kill yourself. Who's the better skier, you or Colbert?
Um, well, I'll say right now, he was terrified and he does that kind of pizza thing where he puts his skis in and he went to French fries, pizza, French fries, pizza, French fries. And he was saying pizza, French fries, pizza, French fries, pizza, French fries. He went down the hill and it was going really slow. And at one point he just sat down and we were on a green. We were on a green. Was he shitting himself at the time?
Did he? Well, I couldn't tell. He said there was shit underneath his bottom where he landed before he lost the valve. So he sat down and then there was shit. And then he said, that's someone else's shit. I just happened to sit here and I said, that's fresh. That is fresh shit. Steam is coming off that shit.
Yeah. Pizza, French fries, fudge. And then he said, yeah, he said, get me a stretcher. I need a stretcher. And he wasn't hurt at all. And then he- Line it with plastic. Yes.
And so it took about an hour to get a stretcher there and they had to wipe the shit off of them. And he was yelling at these people. I think they had to defrost it first, right? He was yelling at them. Yes. He was yelling at them and being very rude. And then I had to ski down with him.
And whenever they went above like three miles an hour, this is on a stretcher. He would go too fast, too fast, too fast, too fast. This is so inflammatory. This is- Yeah. Ask Steven. Ask Steven if this is true and he will tell you it's true. Ask him.
I also love the fact that his family does a focus group after every episode. That's a family that loves you. I think that was back in the day. I don't think they do that anymore. This was back probably earlier when his show was newer and he was excited about it. We needed the feedback. And then we all die inside. We all die.
Clearly. So wait, I want to get back to the mic. My question, you've done over 4,000 hours of television. Here's one of the dumbest questions. Do you still like doing it? No. Okay, great. So my next-
Good night, everybody. I'm so jealous. It is the one thing, one of the things I would love to do. I would love- You'd be very good at it. I don't know about that. I know it's very, very difficult, but it is one thing I always covet it. No, you're doing it now.
No, no. I think you- I'm being honest. I think you would be very good at it. I think Sean would be very good at it. Will would do an attitude all the time and he'd be hard to like, you know. People wouldn't- People wouldn't-
It would all be like, oh, hello, it's so good to see the audience. Because he'd book people like crazy because they would look so good next to him. But you know what I say? I'll take that. Conan, I'll take that because you are an expert on hard to like, so I am going to take that. You know what? Okay. You know what?
Even for you, that was a sloppy swing. That was- And you're a surgeon. You're a surgeon, but you just threw the scalpel across the room. No, you know what? These days, I'm just trying to get on base, man. I'm just- You don't even know whatever it is.
So, the- No, I really do- I do like it. I enjoy- I mean, this is fun. I mean, getting to talk to you guys. And it's the same thing when you have a show. I've interviewed you all on the program and people think, oh, it must be kind of-
It's a job. And I think it is not a job. It is not a job to talk to really funny people who I would happily have dinner with and we would laugh our asses off. That's a joy. The job part comes in when you have to talk to some people who shouldn't be out there. There are people who are booked by publicists because- I think he means Andy.
Yeah, I think he means Andy. Andy Richter is- I don't get it. He's a fool's fool. Well, and look, trust me, I love Andy because I've been taught that that's the thing to say, but- No, I know what you mean about- It's a chore.
It's a job to get through some of those episodes. That's why I asked if you still enjoy it because does that not outweighs the fun guess that make it not a job? But you know, it's great is enough time has gone by and I'm in a nice place, you know, knock wood in my career where I've been around long enough where I don't- If there's someone who I think is going to be really unpleasant to talk to, I just say, let's just not do that person. Good.
When I couldn't have done that in 93, 94, 95, 96. Now I can say, yeah, we just did Sean Hayes like a year ago. Yeah. That's pretty recent. Let's do one is too much. Well, you know, that was the staff talking, not me. That was the consensus. Right.
Of course. And you don't need the- You don't want your audience- Of course, it comes on late at night, but you don't want them going to bed during the show. You know what I mean? So if you have a Hayes on, that's the risk that you run. Yeah, much better for like a RIPAA or-
Oh, he'd be a great RIPAA. He'd be such a great RIPAA. He'd be such a great RIPAA. Behar. Thanks, you guys. Thanks. Of course. You have a very, you have a powerful, powerful RIPAA energy.
Thanks. Is that the first name or the last name? We're not sure. She's not even sure. No one's sure. They've looked at her birth certificate many times and it seems to just, there's multiple copies. Wait a second.
So there were kind of- Wait a minute. You don't interview people. You don't go wait a second. You don't? Oh, wait. Hang on. Can I ask you a question?
Do it like that, Will. Yeah, yeah. Like that. Jason's got the idea. Go ahead. I don't remember seeing your degree from fucking journalism school, man. So listen. How about that?
How about, look, Conan. Do you- Deal with this. What are you- your show had so many- we talked a little bit about when I came and did your podcast and we talked about all the different kind of phases that you went through a little bit on your show. You started out, you were new at doing it and then you guys kind of created this comedy sort of sketch factory over there really in a lot of ways and you were doing so many bits
all the time and it really was a place for guys. We talked about this that guys like me, like I tuned in because I loved watching you guys do that bits and it was you and Stack and you and Brian McCann and John Glazer and all those guys and that was- so like there's been like- it feels like there's been like so many different kind of phases to you being a host of a show. I don't even- Right. Calling you a host is weird.
I remember listening to you talk- I forget who you were talking about, talking to on your podcast, talking about your dad and about how you describe what it is that you do. It's hard to describe because there have been- you're a host but you're also- you're also- you kind of do bit- you're in the bits yourself, like you're doing all this stuff. So- Yeah, I never- it's funny. I never wanted to be a host and I never- when people say, oh, you're a talk show host, oh, that always sounded lame to me and it was not something I wanted to do.
I didn't just want to be a friendly presence. I always wanted us to be coming up with aggressively weird multi-dimensional stuff and I thought, you know, Robert Smigel and I used to talk even before the show went on the air. We had a very specific idea of what the show could be and we thought it's sort of SCTV and Pee Wee's Playhouse and it's Post Letterman because Letterman is irony and detachment. This is going to be very silly and have like children's show elements but also be kind of avant-garde and just ruthlessly like pack as much comedy as we can into each hour and then go do it again.
So the idea that being just a guy who's like, well, welcome to the show, I'm a pleasant fellow and I'm- I go down easy and that was our show. That was never what I wanted to do. And so- And you came off, you'd written on SNL and then you'd- and then you'd gone and written on The Simpsons. It went that way, didn't it? Yeah.
And then SNL and then Simpsons, yeah. And then so you did Simpsons, which again, like that was a very sort of, you know, obviously the time that you were there was really at the infancy of it, the surreal era of The Simpsons and kind of made The Simpsons what they are today. And you brought that kind of energy or that kind of vibe to late night in a way. Like you made it kind of surreal. Well, I'm very, I mean, you know, it's hard not to be boring when talking about your own work, but I'll, and I probably already have been, but it just like sound out live.
My sketches were always very cartoony and silly. And then I went to an actual cartoon, The Simpsons, and really felt comfortable there. And then I think when I got my late night show, there was a lot of Warner Brothers cartoon influence that I wanted to bring into late night. And- Yeah, because you know, when they promote late night talk shows, not just late night, any talk shows, it's almost like the thing that leads the promotion is the guest. And-
And then they would promote your show. I would always tune in because of you, because of all, that was more like a show. It was a sketch show. It was a variety show. You and Mr. T writing, you know, going out to pick apples or whatever. Apple pick. And there was a thing we did where like, to me, it was what we did with the guest. So, you know, years and years ago, we had Tom Selleck on.
And, you know, Tom Selleck, that's a still a good, that's still a great booking. But like then it was just like, oh my God, it's Tom Selleck. And we talked him into, he had just shaved his mustache, we had shaved it like a year before and it was sort of a thing like- For Quigley Down Under? Is that why? I don't know what it was. I swear to God, I don't know what it was for.
It wasn't for a movie, I don't think, but he had, and no reason to throw Quigley Down Under. I think he had lost a bet. Are you impressed with Quigley Down Under? Yeah, that was a great pull. Deep cut. So, there was a bet before you guys did this, I bet I can work in Quigley Down Under and you did it.
Nice going. Nicely done. Yeah. Nicely done. Yeah, and he was just about to say, I think the way to save race relations in America and you went, is Quigley Down Under? And he went, what? And you went, I won the bet, Bateman, I won the bet.
And then Obama lost his train of thought and you guys said, we're out of time, remember that? Well, the worst part was that Obama lost his train of thought. Well, because of your idiocy, no discredit to the great man himself, a good friend of mine by the way. Of course. He's here. He's downstairs, he's making a protein shake.
So anyway, we did this whole thing like, I didn't want to talk to Tom Selleck about his career. We said a whole thing where we said, we found your mustache and your mustache misses you and we reunited him. I remember that. I remember that. And then he came back a second time and he still didn't have the mustache and we said, we reunited you last time and he was like, yeah, yeah, I remember that.
And then we said, well, we got bad news for you, the mustache is terminally ill. And we cut to a little miniature hospital bed and the mustache was dying. And we said, if you have anything as you want to say to the mustache, and there was a nurse there and a doctor. And then of course, Tom Selleck went over to say goodbye to the mustache. And then when he looked both ways and he picked up, he did it really well. He's very funny. Picked up a pillow.
What's happening, how is this a celebrity interview, but now was that cleared with it? Was that part of like the pre-interview and all that stuff, or did you just kind of spring that on him? You know what I'm going to say? I'm going to say we probably told him about it when he got there and he's a good sport and he went along with it. There have been many, we had a, there have been many times where it's gone very badly. Ringo Starr was on the show once and the writers had a funny idea.
Which was, I say, Ringo, do you want to sit in with the, hey, Ringo, why don't you sit in with the band? No, no, I possibly could. No, come on, Ringo, do it. Oh, oh, right. And he walks over there and picks up a saxophone and just starts to wail, which we thought, that's a funny idea. And the band plays out and that would be like a funny clip.
And the writers came to me and I said, you know what, they said it's a beetle, you got to go pitch it to him. And I said, I'll pitch it to him. And I, the writers were like, you know, Conan's going to stand up for us and he's going to really pitch it and sell it. And I went into Ringo's dressing room and I said, oh, Ringo, we have an idea for a bit. And he said, let's hear it.
And I said, so anyway, the idea is I say, hey, Ringo's going to sit in with the band and you cross over, but instead you pick up a saxophone. And without missing a bit, Ringo went, I won't do it. And I, without missing a beat said, and I don't blame you, he went, I won't do it. And I said, and I don't blame you. It's not worthy of you. And it's not a good idea. And the writers like, fuck you, man.
And I'm like, hey, it's not Ringo quality. So forget it. And so, I love selling them out. Have you ever had a guest on the show that went through the publicist said, this is particularly off limits. Do not touch this area. Do not ask this question. And you said, screw it.
And you went ahead with it anyway as a result of them not being a great guest or basically they kind of brought it on themselves. No, I am, you know what? I would not do that. Come on. What if there were just a terrible, you can, you can tell they're not trying at all. They're giving yes, no answers. They're not hitting the ball back and you just, you just unload the noise on them.
You know what? I'm, I'm very, I'm not, I'm going to be really serious about this. It's not even a moral choice. It's not, some people are really funny, you know, when they, like I think David Letterman, one of his, and it's, I think one part of his brilliance is he can be this incredibly, he can be this wit that eviscerates people and, and, and, and really brilliantly and, and really brilliant. And people that deserve it, I don't have, I'm not good at that.
I can actually do it with my friends when I'm kidding and I know that their feelings won't really be hurt. I can be incredibly, I can really unload on them and I think be artfully mean or artfully sarcastic when they know the deal with me and it's safe. There's a safe word. That doesn't transfer on TV or with people that you don't know and I, whenever I've done, this is true. Whenever I do bits where I commit a hundred percent and I'm a complete asshole, I can
feel the crowd. They don't love it. They don't love it because they do think they are seeing mostly me, even though I'm also participating in bits. They are seeing mostly me and you have such a great, you know, vulnerable, baked in vulnerability and like non-assholiness that you could probably get away with being a whole lot more. What are you watching? I'd love to see you try to be a super duper asshole to want to, you should just pick one
and just give us a text, just give us a little heads up, tune in tonight, I'm going to fire bullets. You know what I do? No, I could find, there have been one, there have been sketches where I'm a complete over the top creep and it has worked, but I think it took a long time. People had to get to know the real me to then, I mean, early in the show, I think we had the gymnast Mary Lou Retin on, this is how long the show has been on. I had a crazy crush on her.
We had Mary Lou Retin on and we did a bit where I just completely unload on her and I committed a hundred and ten percent. America's sweetheart? You kind of think better than that. Yes, and we thought it would be really funny and I completely, well, that was the whole idea is that she just said something really innocent. It was one of those things we taped in a commercial break and then we saved it and then, you know, a week later Andy went, yeah, we're getting some, you know, I'll do Andy, sorry.
We're getting some blowback and I went, what do you mean, you were kind of rough on Mary Lou Retin. No, I wasn't. Yeah, you are. Take a look at the clip and I completely unload on her and I had people on the street saying, you know what, I am never watching you again. Yeah. Why do you hate America?
Why did you treat it her? And I'm like, it's clearly a bit, it's, you know, yeah. When you did Arrested, I think I've told you this before, one of my favorite laughs on Arrested ever was when you were on it and Andy is standing next to you, getting your makeup done backstage or something like that. I forget why Michael Bluth is there to talk to you or whatever. Anyway, you're getting your makeup done and Andy walks by and he stops and he's looking at you and you finish talking to me and you say to him, you say, hey, Andy, by the way,
next time I stopped talking, that's not your cue to talk. It was the biggest, it was so dry, it was without any cover whatsoever, it was the biggest asshole thing. Yeah. It's fun. It's fun. It is fun to be incredibly, just with anyone, it's really fun to turn it, as you guys know. We had a, one of our writers is this brilliant, brilliant writer and really brilliant comic
Lori Kilmartin. She's just fantastic and she's one of my favorite people and this is a little heavy, but she lost her mom recently to COVID and she wrote these tweets about it that were funny and powerful at the same time and just sort of perfect and we decided to talk to her on the show and we just did a couple of days ago and I talked to her about it and it was this really powerful segment and she's talking about losing her mom, but she's also, you know, she's being funny, but she's also, she's walking this razor's edge and then finally it got a little emotional and she said, but I really missed my mom and I said, well,
Lori, I'm just a huge fan and you're fired, you know, and I just, and it was, it was, it was such the wrong thing to do at the wrong moment that firing her at that moment was just so much fun. She laughed. Yeah. No, very upset. Come on. Then I had to fire her.
And because of what he did, here's the thing, he always follows through with his bits, so he actually fired her. I did let her go because she didn't laugh immediately and that I won't have. Right. How do you like doing the show from home? Would you do it that way forever and for always if you could? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I think, I think we can all agree here, gentlemen, that one must, I, maybe you guys won't agree.
I believe that the way a salmon swims upstream to spawn in the morning, I have to get it in a car. Beautiful. Thank you. Keep going. I have to get in a car, just like a salmon does, and drive an electric car. Wait, you're not. Yeah.
Did I go too far? No. The salmon has an electric car and lives on the west side of LA. Wait, wait, wait. Let's stop. Just so I can understand the rules. So there's a salmon that lives on the west side of LA. Yeah.
Yes. And it has an electric car. And it's beloved. It's beloved and very hard to book on a podcast and it's really the exception when it does someone else's podcast because it has its own podcast. Why would it do someone else's? Anyway, the point is the salmon is, and the salmon's had an eye job recently and it hasn't gone well.
Wow. The salmon's busy. Yeah. The salmon's name is Cronin. And anyway, I believe you've got to get up in the morning, like the salmon in the car with the eye job, and you have to go to work. Does the salmon look like it's combed its hair with a pork chop too, or what is the deal?
Now, Will, this is our guest. Pork chop. What is, what is? You know, that's not, what does that mean? I will say there's not as much body in the pork chop with your home version of Cronin as there is in the stage where you could tell me. Ask any engineer. Yeah.
I have not had a haircut in quite a while. What happens when the upper shelf was pure weight, it's pure weight, the shelf collapsed about three weeks ago and it happened in the night. It happened in the night and three workmen were killed and it happened in the night and it woke everyone up and, and I came running out and people said, what was that? And I suddenly had bangs and, you came running out in your night shirt in your long, I did. Yeah. I looked like Mo Howard circa 1968 in a night shirt and I came running out and I said, what
happened, what happened? And they went your hair. It fell for the first time since 93. And I no longer had that iconic Conan pump and it, there's nothing I can do right now. I know I'm sort of have like a Sean Cassidy. It's feathery. It blows back. I carry a fan around.
I'm very popular with the ladies. It's a whole new life. That hair and that face and that height and the shoulders and everything, that's what I said. I was talking about the shoulders. What's the shoulders? No, it's like you build houses on the weekends, right? I mean, look at you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. So what Will was saying at the beginning, you can't hide. How do you, how do you like when you're out amongst your people and people, you know, they come up and they, and they got, they got compliments or they got notes or whatever the hell they've got for you. Do you like talking to America?
Are you, are you a shy guy or? Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. And they had to quote the great Lord, Michael's no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I mean, it's ridiculous. They tire, they approached me and say, Hey, I'm really happy to meet you. I start talking and then they give me a clear. Well, anyway, it was a thrill to meet you and I say, but you said that you're from Florida.
Would that be the panhandle or the coast? And they're like, and they're actually walking away and I'm walking towards them and. He's got a T-shirt that says, ask to take a selfie with me. Yeah. Someone rated celebrities on friendliness. Come on. And this is a book that came out like,
no, like 15 years ago, some autograph hounds. I think two guys wrote a book. And I think I, I'm not bragging here cause I think it's more sad than anything else, but I got like one of the highest ratings for just, oh, this guy will walk you to your car and clean the room. How does your wife feel about that? And how do your kids feel about that?
Do they get weirded out when people come up and start talking to their dad? No, they're, they're very cool. My wife is very nice and she will often offer to take the picture to make it better. I mean, she's, I'm very lucky cause I know, you know, some people have a spouse that's like, oh my God, why is it about you?
Sean. Yeah. Well, yes. You've met Scotty, right? I mean. Oh my God. Did I meet Scotty? Punch you right in the neck.
But I just changed his batteries. He's right back up and running. All right, baby, does Amanda take a lot of photos for other people? Her favorite trick is just let me take it and then she'll flip the camera around, she'll take a couple of headshots of herself and hand it back and go, good ones.
Thoreau used to do that with, when he was like running with Ben Cyiller, he told me that people would have to take a photo with Ben Cyiller and he go, yeah, I'll take it. And he'd frame Ben out and then he'd get back and then they keep walking. That's great. That's great.
And they'd be like, hey, I actually had happened to me in New York, the biggest cliche ever. Somebody, there was a big family and they came up to me and they said, would you mind taking a photo? And I was like, sure. And then they handed me the camera. Yes, guess what? Happened to me a week ago on the beach in Carpentaria,
a bunch of people from Phoenix, Arizona walked up and said, oh my God, would you mind? And I went, no, and they held up the camera and then they asked me to take a picture of them. Now I was wearing a mask, but the mask said, I am Conan O'Brien. So I was hurt. I had that too, I had that same mask.
I did a mask, I did it with this Sharpie last week for a meeting on Zoom where I wrote my name, I'm Will O'Neill on the mask. And then I got worried because we went to pick up some takeout and I said to my girlfriend, I went out of the car, I got out of the car for a second, I was about to pick it up and I came back and I go, I'm not wearing the one that says,
no, no, you're good. I wouldn't let you out of the car. Can I ask a quick question? I can, I'm a master at painting a verbal picture. I know what the question is. As shoulders and arms today. And then smile as legs and back. No, no, no, that's what we're talking about me again.
Okay. My question is most, the three of us, three of us, of the four of us, are in just a natural environment, hanging out in our homes. Will, you are in, clearly, you are at Abbey Road Studios in London and you are in a professional booth. What's your deal?
What's your problem? The deal is, you don't have to go into VO voice because you're in a VO room. Were you doing a Ford truck ad? GMC, careful Conan. Oh, sorry, sorry. GMC, we are professional grade. Friends don't let friends drive Fords.
Listen, here's the thing. This is just me being me. I wanted to ask you because you're one of the funniest people on the face of the earth. Are you still contributing every single day to thinking of 1,000 bits for your show or do you solely rely at this point on your writers
and you occasionally chime in? Are you walking around your house thinking of bits constantly? You want me to admit to being a rotted husk. No, not at all. It doesn't give a shit anymore. Yeah, do you have a little bit book in your pocket? I don't have a bit book,
but I do remember, I think of things a lot of times and I'll just act them out and that's how some of my favorite things that are really stupid that I've done, I want to give it up to my writers. They write the lion's share of the stuff and they've written the lion's share of the stuff that's iconic over the years and so,
but I had a bit in my back pocket that I love which is always called Who Stole the Fudge? And it was just me saying like, now we're going to do a segment called Who Stole the Fudge? And I did this actually during the first early COVID shows because I'm sitting right where I'm sitting now. I have no writers initially. I had no idea what I was going to do
and I was just saying like, oh, I'll do this bit that I thought of. And so I literally just had some melted chocolate fudge frosting behind me in a little cup and I just went, well, there's a little bit called Who Stole the Fudge? Hold on a second. And then I just turn around and I say Who Stole the Fudge? And I whip around and my face is smeared with it.
And I go, huh, fudges? Someone took fudge? And then I just totally do a, I didn't know, no, I've not seen fudge. I hope. And then the thing is like, I'll help you look. I'll help you. And it's so-
Your network immediately stopped payment on the check. Well, you know what's so crazy about that story? This is absolutely true. Bateman, I'm not sure if you were there. Sean, I'm pretty sure you were there. The three of us used to play cards together for years and years ago and Andy would often play with us. And one time in my old place in Venice,
remember I was in that place and Bradley was right in the thing next door. Well used to live right next to Bradley Cooper. Yeah, who'd you live above? Ron Rivkin. Yeah. Ron Rivkin and his wife from the front, Bradley Cooper and I were in the back.
We had the back house. Well, such a threesome. Did the three of you guys ever do stuff together? Did you ever go down to Santa Monica Pier? Professional stuff or stuff? You mean stuff. Stuff in italics. We never did stuff together, man.
You mean that night, like when the lights are out? Oh, continue with your... Welcome to the podcast. So anyway, so one night we're playing cards and I'm not kidding, very similarly, somebody had bought some, I think Pete Giles had bought some cookies or fudge or something and Andy, somebody said,
hey Andy, when you're up there, can you bring that, bring that chocolate down? And the same, but it's a fucking classic. I don't know why I'm telling this. We'll cut this part out. We'll just leave yours in. No, no, no, no, it's... But Andy came down and he had fudge,
and he goes, I couldn't find you. You wasn't in, you were not in. Yeah, Andy did, Andy did a thing. I remember one of the first things he did, we were in some, I think we were taping a show and the lights just suddenly went out, which was, I mean, there was some power surge or failure at 30 Rock and the lights went out
and without missing a beat, Andy shrieked, my pearls. And I was just like, this classic sort of Merck's brothers, three Stooges, my pearls. I love that. They're gone. And I was just like, okay, that guy's got a great fastball. Hey, what do you, you've been doing this for so long. You've been doing a talk show and a podcast
and it seems like you're never not interviewing somebody or in that world. Is there anything else you wanna do or you're doing it or do you wanna just keep doing this for the rest of your life? Well, I don't think you can ever say, I wanna keep doing this. It just keeps changing and evolving.
And I think when it's time to, I think show business has changed. It used to be that you had to say, well, farewell, and people used to announce like, think of, it's not 1992, Johnny Carson says, well, that's it, goodbye and farewell and waves goodbye to America. And then literally ascends on a beam of light
and rides a unicorn into the sunset. And now I feel like- That's just for me. That's for you. You're the only one that has Carson's stature today. But no, I just feel like my answer to that is I like to make things. And I know when I'm, if I'm involved in something
I don't like to do, I have the luxury of saying, you know, this doesn't feel good and I don't wanna do this. But if I like something and I like to do it and I'm enjoying it, then I'll keep doing it. And I don't know when that runs out. So it may just keep morphing. I mean, I do think with the internet and with the world we're in now,
there'll be 100 million talk shows within like five years. So it's not like, and I'm not saying this to be humble, but if I went away tomorrow and wasn't doing a show, America would have no withdrawal. There'd be no like, well, that happened because there's so much out there. There's so much turnover. But the other thing is they have no withdrawal
from anybody or anything anymore. So there's no, everything's so disposable. And so you produce quite a lot of stuff or you've had a production company for a long time and you've produced various things. Do you see, and you produce a lot of stuff with Jeff Ross, right? He's your partner.
Yeah, yeah. What's that relationship like, by the way? So you guys started, he was the producer of the show. Did you guys know each other before? No, Lorne put us together. Lorne Michaels, I've sat on it live, he was the one. And he said, you're gonna be working with Jeff Ross. And so Jeff Ross was the guy who I was sort of partnered
with, that's all Lorne. And it was just sort of peanut butter, not peanut butter and jelly, something not quite as good as that. Stand up, Jeff Ross, the, the, the, the, No, not that Jeff Ross. That's Jeff Reross and he's the roast master general. Jeff Ross is our executive producer.
And yeah, he's, we sort of do everything together and it just works. His, my heart rate, my resting heart rate is like, you know, 225 and his is like 15 beats an hour. He's like a tortoise that will be alive in 600 years. So with that heart rate, does that go into your social life as well, or do you find that you kind of automatically click into the opposite?
In other words, I've been doing this all day. I've been asking questions all day. I've been coming up with bits all day. And now when I go out to dinner with my wife and another couple, do you find that you just, instinctually, you just would rather answer questions than ask them? Like, how are you so sure?
No, I, I think I have a hard time slowing it down. I'm constantly, I do bits all the time. I do bits in the mirror. I do bits when no one's there. Do your kids think you're funny? Yeah, they do. They do. You know, now that they're teenagers,
that the joke is that I'm lame and I'm a boomer and an idiot. And I think that that's only gonna last another 40 years, but you know what my trick for that is, I actually say to my nine year, I've said to my nine year old within the last two days, okay, boomer to my nine year old. And I just, I go on the offensive with them. Right, right, right.
That's very good. That's very good. And probably blocking some real creative growth for your child. It's not me, it's them. What about your wife? Does she think you're funny? Or do you have to, do you find that your material is just?
No, no, she's genuinely, I can genuinely make her laugh. She's great. We've been together 20 years, been married for 18 and she still laughs and finds me amusing. And I can get her cause it's just, she loves silly stuff, but she will hear me in the bathroom. Like I've gone to brush my teeth or sometimes I'll get up at night to like just, you know,
urinate and then I'll be, she'll just hear like, oh, you think so, eh? You know, and she'll be like, what? There's no one in there that's not for anybody. And I, it doesn't turn off. And I, when I was at the Simpsons, there's a great, one of the great Simpsons writers, Mike Reese, once just, when I had done like a long run
and people were laughing in the room. He just looked at me and he just went, what would it be like to be you? Like at night? And it was this missile that, and what does it, he wasn't trying to be mean. He was just curious, like, what's the pathology of that like when you're trying to calm down?
And it, it's problematic at times. You know, I had, I had a, the other day, so I have a young baby boy. And the other day, it's yesterday, I was, he was sort of crying. I was holding it and walking around with him and my girlfriend, I could hear her coming around in the corner, so I just started doing this bit,
knowing that she would eventually come up. But she thought like, what are you doing? And as she comes around, I'm going, right? And the question, you'll always want to find out who did let the dogs out? Because nobody knows who that was. And I was doing it really quietly around the corner. She was like, the fuck are you doing?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. This is, this is a bit for, if she hadn't come, it would have been a bit for none. And it was maybe gonna be a bit for one. But I understand that same inclination, which is like, you can't stop. Yeah. I want to say this about everybody on this call,
which is we all were a certain way, and then we were lucky enough to find an industry that would pay us to be that way. Yeah, for sure. That's my feeling about it. It's not, oh my God, we've got to work so hard to contort ourselves to be the person who can then be in that industry.
I really do think any other, I'm very humble because I think of all of human history and in any other point in human history, my job would have been probably in Ireland to move a stone from one part of the field to the other. And people would have just hated me. Yeah, you would have gotten fired with bits. He's not good at it.
Yeah, he spends time on his hair. He's using a pork chop to comb his hair. He's being a, that's a classic joke. Yeah, I don't know. You know, it's interesting you say that, because I have, my heart rate is as fast as yours, I think, and I have, I'm high anxiety almost all the time. And I actually found a job
in the character I played on Will and Grace. That, all of that energy, that's actually anxiety. And I found an outlet for it. You know, I just happened to find the right part to let out all my anxiety. So people are like, oh my God, you so much energy when you come through the door on the show. And you do, you know, you jump around like a ferret,
like a gay ferret. And I'm like, yeah, you know, it's all my like anxiety. Like I can't, you know, calm down. And what is Will and Grace? Yeah, so it's, it's a- Just wait a minute for the story. Why, you see, you know what, and this is again, why I think I'm talking to two great natural hosts.
And then I'm talking to Will as well, who you interrupt with your hateful bits and they're sarcastic and there's an oily kind of cool. You've got that Canadian, there's a lot of stuff going on there. And no one's gonna attach to that. People really like Sean and they really like, they really do, they like Sean and they,
no, I was gonna get to Jason, but they like Sean, they feel a warmth there and they feel like Jason's like a human being. And then Will, you've just like, you never let anybody in. I've never seen you look me in the eye. You've got the eyes of a doll, a doll's eyes, a doll's eyes.
Full of shark eyes, full of shark eyes. Because I don't want anybody to see that how dead it is in here. How dead. But Sean, but Sean, truly you do have, you are like a high octane person as well. Like you can't, and you can't sit still ever. Yeah, I know.
Well, you know, I wanna say something, which is that, and I think I'm right to be heard, finally a little air time on this show. No, I have to speak once at least to earn the check, I guess. But I had a meal, not long ago, but pre-COVID with Sean, and Scottie was there and my wife was there.
And it was, we were all paid to do it. It was a paid appearance. Scottie paid, yeah, Scottie paid. And he had to pay Sean as well, which was weird. But he paid Sean, he paid Liza, and he paid me. All comes out in the wash. Yeah, whatever. But no, we had this meal and afterwards,
and lots of laughing and really delightful. And then afterwards, we're just like driving home. Why, if it's like, it's, you know, was just commenting. I forget exactly how she said it, but just like, oh, to watch the two of you, meaning two of the same kind, that came from the same part of the factory that were made the same year,
that have the same engine in them, opposite each other is, it was really fun. And I thought, oh my God, I felt it too. I felt like, oh, he's got that hummingbird thing going on in his head. And, yeah. And guys like Jason and me, we're much, we're kind of cooler and realer.
Yeah, totally. We kind of got that kind of real. Kind of yendy yang. But on that, like your wife, you find is the opposite of you. And like with Sean, with Scottie, he's sort of the opposite too. Is that sort of like the right balance?
Absolutely, yeah. Where I'm the opposite with Amanda. Amanda, she goes a mile a minute and I just sit there kind of half, you know, alive. And I'll just, I'll throw a bomb every once in a while. Just kind of cherry pick some sort of snarky thing to say. I think that's why we're all in long-term relationships, right?
Is because it's the yendy of the yang. Yeah, right. Yeah. No, I think why it's, it's why all four of us are well, you know, very successful. Yeah, I know, right? I'll tell you a funny, the true story, which is that Amy used to always roll her eyes
when Conan and I would do bits and she would get mad and she'd be like, oh, she'd be like exhausted by us fucking around. And then when I saw Conan right after Amy and I split up, we ran into each other at the Beverly Hills Hotel. We were going to talk about this before. And then he came back and he was like, oh, thank God, we can finally, she's gone and we can finally be ourselves.
We can do our bits. And, you know, I love Amy, but she, you know what? I love Amy, but she would, the problem is there are certain people who I cannot, and I think I just cannot be, I have to do bits. Do bits, like the first time I met, it's Will, yeah, Will. The first time I met Will, I'd never met him before and I just knew him from Arrested Development.
And it was, you know, everyone was raving about the show and I go to the Emmys and I walk into the room and way across the room I see Will and he's over on the other side of the big ballroom at the governor's ball after the Emmys. And I see him way across the room and he sees me in our eyes lock. He starts to slowly retreat.
I start to advance and then he's running and I'm running after him. Oh my God, I've done that bit a million times. Yeah, and it's like- And we've never met. We've never met. And there are people like you, Jack McBrayer of 30 Rock fame, I've never in my life had a real,
whenever I see, and I've known Jack for 15 years and he's a lovely guy, but whenever he would come by the show, when we taped the show in Rock For Our Center, he'd like just come by and I'd immediately go into, well, well, well, country, and I'd become the city slicker asshole to his country bumpkin. And I'd be like, I didn't know they stacked shit that high, boy, and he would get act real hurt and go,
now, sir, you stop and I go, did you get scared in the elevator? Cause the room moved. And so what happened was people would, he was in on it, cause he was totally playing the part of, sir, I resent that you think I've never written in it, you know, but everyone else, we committed to it so much that the crew had a talk with me at one point and said,
you know what, Jack's a good guy and he comes by and he does bits and the way, and the way you treat him. And I'm like, what? And I told Jack McBrayer and he was howling, but to this day, I think if, if Jack was in like a terrible car accident or vice versa, if I was in a terrible car accident and Jack visited me in the hospital and I was there with tubes going into me,
I went, hello, he'd call me Mr. O'Brien and go, hello there, Mr. O'Brien. And I'd be on, literally on life support and I'd be, I'd go like, well, well, where'd you put, did they let your donkey in the ER? Is your donkey in the ER there, countryfeller? And he'd go, sir, I don't appreciate, you know. Conan, you accuse me once of the,
if you were in the middle of China and you needed help and you ran across me that I would just do a bit and not help you. So, and I would go along with the bit. And you'd go along with the bit and be, you know what's crazy and some of this stuff we will keep in some we don't have to, but what's crazy is when I went in and I'm doing 30 rock
and I'd known Jack for years, cause he used to, he was at UCB all the time and he, you know, he started doing Ascat on Sunday nights and whatever. So I knew him and I, we had a similar sort of fo adversarial relationship always. Like I'd see McBrown be like, Jesus, what? McBrown, what the fuck, you know, so I take it to set.
So we're on set and Alec is there and then Jack comes on to set and I'm like, oh, fucking Jack's in this. Okay, like, you know, whatever. And like Carlos there and those guys and I'm fucking around. And Alec says to me, hey, you know, Jack's very sensitive. You might want to take it easy.
And I'm like, no, no, no, no, no, man, I got this. You're, I'm all good. I told, I, I got on a years and years ago and it was when Will Ferrell had been on Saturday Night Live for like, I don't know, maybe two years, three years. And he was, his star was on the rise. He was well known and he was really starting to click.
And I had to take a flight. I think it was from LA to New York or New York to LA somewhere and I get on the flight and I sit in my seat and I knew Will just because he would sometimes come down and do bits, he'd literally be up at Saturday Night Live. It's the middle of the week, he'd have an idea for a bit. He'd come down, he'd say, I have this idea of this guy and would be like, great and we'd do it.
And it would be hilarious. So this was, you know, before he was even on much as a guest, he would do these bits for us. So Will, Will Ferrell sits down in the seat next to me, just total chance. And I go, oh, hell, hey, hey, hey, within seconds. I'm doing a bit. I had a big book in my lap and I was like, ah, books,
and I kept rubbing the book and he'd go, and then he just went into the improv thing of, oh, you like, oh, books, books, books of my life, Will, books. And it was a whole bit about how the more he talked to me, the more it became clear that I can't even read. That I've never read a book and I'm overcompensating. The flight, as you all know, is a five and a half hour flight. I never, ever asked him, how are you?
Yeah. He never asked me, are you married? What's this? The whole thing was like, but books. And then he'd get up and come to the back and that, you know, and then I'm reading it upside down. And he's saying, you know, you might wanna turn to the, don't you talk to me.
That's so funny. It's funny, but there's something wrong. But he didn't ask you, he didn't ask you to be married. He probably thought you were a confirmed bachelor. That was kind of the thing, right? You were, it was confirmed that you were a bachelor at the time. I used to make very public appearances
with Tippi Hedrin and there'd be photographs and stuff. But there's a nice coziness when you meet somebody like that. There's a nice familiarity, right? I think so. There's like, you know, it's... I think we're all kindred spirits in that. And the thing is it's, we all have friends like this too.
This is not like some show business club. There's a million people out there in the world who don't happen to be in show business who are orthopedic surgeons or, you know, they landscape or they, you know, they drive a trash truck and they do the same thing. It's a kind of spirit that I really love are people that are just, and you pick it up.
I mean, I've done, we've all like, you've been at a Costco or something like I've been to a Costco. I'm sorry, I can't sell that. Well, that's the podcast guys. That's it. That's the last word. I'm living in a house made of gold. Anyway.
Wait, I have a quick... No, no, I want to break in for a second and bring up a point here, which is that I happen to know for a fact that Will Arnett only flies private and did long before he could afford it. He has his own plane and this is a true story. Two years ago, he had the Rolling Stones tongue logo painted on the back of the plane,
which is just fucking confusing. Why would you, it's confusing. People think the Rolling Stones are in town and then you get off the plane and people are like, oh yeah, from the show and the voice of the truck. But why, why did you do that? The voice of the truck. Voice of the truck.
But why did you do that? Why did you feel the need to do that? Here's the thing. First of all, you know I'm a huge Stones fan. I've never disguised that. I've always been really upfront. I love, ever since I saw Apocalypse Now, that was the first time I heard him.
And then I was a big, I saw them. That's the doors. And I saw the Steel Wheels tour was the greatest Stones tour. I don't know if you guys happen to see the Steel Wheels. You know what, Steel Wheels is their best album. Is their best album. And I saw them in 1993 at Sky Dome in Toronto.
I saw them at Sky Dome. I don't know if you've ever been there. Incredible place to see. You want to talk about ambiance. So that's why I did that. And also I got, the Rolling Stones asked me to paint it on my plane. Is that true?
That's a true story. Mick Jagger. Wait, are you kidding me? No, so Keith Richards owed me $11 million because I had gone into receivership. Okay, so you know in the Palisades, if you're going west on Sunset. Yes.
That's the part of every story where you know it's a lie. Whenever someone's going says like, okay, wait a minute. You know when you're in the Palisades and you're going west on Sunset, then you know because when they were interrogating Oswald, there was about 28 hours before Oswald's killed when they have him in custody.
And he was like, I didn't do it. I didn't do it. I didn't do it. And they put you work in the building. You bought the gun. And at one point he went, you know when you're in the Palisades going west on Sunset and that's when they knew they had him.
And just then Jack Ruby shot him. And so that's a fact too. That's a golden, that's a fact. That's a fact. Conan out of, really out of left field. Did you always want to go to Harvard? Was it a fair, complete that you were going to get into Harvard?
Was it like a done deal? Did you? How could it be a done deal? How could it? I don't know. Like did you, did you have, I thought about it. Did you have crazy good grades?
No, I was the, you know, so funny because I get this reputation as, oh, you went to Harvard. So you just- No, that's not out there. Yeah. Never heard that. Yeah. And people think, oh, you were just really smart.
And I think, wow, my experience of being a kid was no one in my family, my parents are very smart people, but no one had gone to Harvard college. And I was in the middle of the family and I was very anxious. I had a lot of anxiety and I decided, I think around the fourth or fifth grade, I've just got to be a great student.
And so I was a grind. I was, it was nothing funny about it. I was funny with my friends, but then I would take impeccable notes. I would go up to my little room in the attic and I would grind and I ground my way in. And I just decided I'm going, I didn't know exactly that I was going to Harvard,
but then when I got in, I thought, okay, I'm going there. And it was only when I got there that I realized, oh, they've got this comedy magazine that's seminal and amazing, the lampoon. And I went, that was just like a, that was not the reason for going there, but that's what changed my life. So I was a total grind who ended up working really hard
to get into this great college and then found comedy by doing that. And so that was, it's kind of a weird show, entrance into show business, I think, when you think about it. What did you think you were going to study there? When I got there, I studied, I was a pretty serious student. I studied history and literature of America,
but I thought I'd be either a very serious writer or I'd get into government. And I'd probably get a law degree and I just, I would follow some kind of track. And it was only, I mean, I knew immediately when people on the lampoon sort of said to me when I was 18 and they were 21 or 22, you're a very funny young fellow. That meant a lot to me and that changed my life.
I didn't, I thought, I knew I was a funny guy with my friends, but suddenly people that seemed like full grown adults to me who were headed off into the world were telling me, you've got something, kid. And that just changed everything for me. So that's cool. Same. So.
I used to run into you at Harvard. I remember that. Yeah, all the time. I loved her. I used to, man, it was so good and just around with all the buildings and stuff. And it was so cool. You know, I didn't think you went,
when you mentioned buildings, I knew that you had sealed the deal. Only you knew about it. What dorm did you stay in? John F. Kennedy International Center for Dormitories. Man, it was unbelievable. Again, I'll take your word for it. No, arguing with this guy.
No, I do wish one thing, which is, I mean, I'm very proud that I went there and I worked hard and I met a lot of really amazing people. And, but I wish no one knew because I do think there are times on the talk show over the years where people can just say, well, I didn't go to Harvard and you just feel like, oh, shit. Like, I don't know.
I think suddenly that maybe that's off-putting to other people and I know because I went there that like any other school, it's a very flawed place. I met some very smart people, some incredibly stupid people. And yeah. Well, there are a lot of people who lead with it, right? That's sort of their thing that they, of course, for the rest of their life.
With a question mark at the end of it, though. I went to Harvard. Harvard? Yeah, like we don't know. Well, so I didn't go, but my dad went to Harvard and he never talks about it or he never mentions it. Right. And it's just not a thing that he-
That's the first time I've heard of that. Yeah, yeah. You know, what's interesting is I went to First Lady Michelle Obama had some event to get kids to really get excited about registering for college or trying to go to college. And she had this event and she asked a lot of people and I was one of them.
I'm sure I was the first call, but there wasn't a call sheet but I would have been pretty high. But she asked a lot of people to show up at UCLA and do this thing. And she said, oh, and everyone wear your, a sweatshirt from your college. Like that'll be a fun thing. And I just couldn't, I can never do that.
So I didn't. I just wore a jean jacket and a shirt. You wore a sweatshirt from college, from when you went there. You're supposed to wear a, or just, or if you don't have it, go out and buy one. You're supposed to wear, and I just didn't,
you know, obviously I don't wanna walk, I'm not gonna walk around. I spent, it's funny. I worked so hard to get into the place and then I got in and then I graduate. And the minute I graduated, I started backtracking on that's where I went to school. It's amazing that if Jason and Gunny
and his sweatshirt were to set Teen Wolf two. Yeah. Teen Wolf two you. You know. Teen Wolf two you. So. That stigma you talk about of having Harvard on your back, you know, it's,
I know what you mean. Like, so what is it makes you feel extra pressure that you don't want? You know, because would you have felt the same way if you went to a state school? No, I don't, I mean, I don't know. I can't answer that question. I just think it gets, I don't like,
I hate being put in any kind of box in any way. Even if it's a box that other people would think, oh, I would love to be in that box. I resent it. And I know that sounds strange because there are probably a lot of people out there that think like, well, that's a good thing that you went there.
And I am proud of it, but I remember before when I was announced as this guy named Conan O'Brien is going to replace David Letterman. And everyone's wondering who is this guy? All they knew about me is that I had gone to Harvard and I kept reading, oh, so it's going to be this urbane. Right. You know.
It's like you can't be funny and have a six pack. Exactly. This is Will's problem. Oh yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah. Check this out. Conan, when do you think that you're going to get into comedy?
Yeah. Like when do you think that will happen? A good question. Well, cause you talk a lot about it. Well, I've been a long time fan and it's just working up the nerve to just say, I think I'm ready and to go ahead and do it. And just say like, do it.
And I was like, hang on, I'm going to write down a couple of numbers. I know some people that you can call. Okay. And then you can just, you know. Okay. Give him a call. Okay.
This is fantastic. I really appreciate this. Of course, dude. You're such a good guy. Now who is, I'm looking at the, who is Richard kind? I'm supposed to call Richard kind? God, I love him. By the way.
I love Richard kind. He's a perfect dude. A perfect dude. 818. 818. Lives deep in the valley. I'll call this Richard kind, but I want to do it. And I think I'm ready to do it.
So I, you know, the nice thing is you guys encouraging me. That's the nice thing. He's got two numbers. He's got 818 and he's also in New York. He's also 718. So he's 818. Okay. He's never at the center of things.
Is he? No. I feel like we're being real greedy with him. Yeah. We're being greedy with our time. Conan, you've been so generous. Incredibly kind of you. Listen, I, I'm going to be very honest with you.
I try to avoid other podcasts like the plague. And then when they told me that you three had a podcast, I said, I will, I will pay to do that. That's so sweet. Three of the, no seriously. Three of the, of the funniest people I know and just getting to hang out with you guys was incredibly fun. And so thanks for having me.
I really mean that. Thank you, my friend. Very nice of you to say yes. You're a lovely people. So great having you. No, two of you, just to be here with, with Bateman and, and Sean to be, there's the two of you mean so much to me and there's one I'll never know.
And I don't think anyone will ever know him because he'd make a terrible host. He's unknowable. He's a shell with a voice. Well, I'm going to get out on that note. Thank you, Conan. We love you. Conan, we love you.
We thank you. Really fun, you guys. Thank you so much. That was, that was a joy. And I'll see you all later. Okay. That was fun. Goodbye, pal.
Thank you. Murderers, killers, murderers, murderers, murderers. That Conan, I do like that Conan. Me too. He's so funny. You know, I didn't want to get into the tonight's show stuff because I'm sure he's so sick of talking about it, but he was the best on that.
I mean, he was hilarious. God, he handled himself so well and that whole thing too, it was amazing. And I was thinking about it today before we did the show. I was thinking like we've all known him a long time and he was, you know, I got to know him from doing the show and we became friends and hung out a bunch and then he goes
and he does the tonight show. And it was like such a great kind of crowning moment for him that he got given that gig. And then to have that whole thing kind of soured and kind of robbed from him in the way that it was was so particularly cruel. And I tell you, man, he handled it with such grace. And you know, the silver lining about all that
is that you root for him. You just don't never stop rooting for him because of, not just because of that because he's brilliant, but you know, I just wish for him to continue succeeding because he deserves it. Same, same. Jason's not saying anything because Jason's not a fan.
Yep. Yeah, no, I've got notes on him. I always have. Um, can we call him back? Yeah, yeah, that's gonna back up. No, I'm a huge fan of his. I'm glad what he said about how, because of the internet and what,
like he's never going to go away. I love that there's like a guarantee that there's so much turnover in this business. And I love that he's not over it, that he doesn't run out of bits, that he's gonna be around forever. I love that. He is just a naturally funny guy.
Yeah, for sure. That's it. And he has no choice about it. For sure, yeah. It's not a skill. It's not a thing, a muscle. It's just that's- You just are, yeah.
You just are. Yeah, I agree. And he is. And kind and personable. He's really kind. He's a perfect host. I love what he says he doesn't consider himself a host, but he's like, by definition,
somebody you want to hang out with, even at your quietest moment in your home at night, you know, like 11, 30, like there's not a lot of people I want there, you know? Yeah, for sure. Okay, guys, so that was great, right? Having Conan on? One of the best ones.
So great, so great. Yeah, I mean, I could talk to him forever. I knew you guys would be excited about Conan. I love, yes, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great. What's his last name? I never caught it. I never caught it.
You don't need a last one when you got a first one like that. When your name's Conan? Right? Yeah. I remember when he first came on, everyone was like, is it Conan or Conan? Yeah.
I do remember that. No one knew how to pronounce it. I still sometimes do it when I go on a show, I'll go, I'll go, well, good to see you, Conal. And he'll go, it's Conan. I go, it is? I've done that, I've done that to him a bunch of times. What? That's your name?
Conan with an N? Conal. What? Wow. Okay. Good guess, Willie. Thanks, boys. Great episode.
Hey, listen, I guess it goes without saying, but... Bye-bye. Smart. Last. Smart. It was all good. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.